sham referendums annexations and a large
conscription Drive Vladimir Putin is
trying to salvage his special military
operation it means that this illegal war
on Ukraine has now arrived in the middle
of Russian Society but opposition seems
to be growing protests are increasing
and thousands of Russian men are
fighting age are fleeing conscription
through Exodus of well-educated men has
begun they refuse to die for Putin's
Imperial Ambitions we ask on to the
point protests and mass flight is Russia
finally turning on Putin
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let me introduce today's panel Maria
McKeever a journalist from Russia
currently living and working in Berlin
and editor-in-chief of the Russian
language TV channel OST West
Daniel bresler correspondent for the
German broadsheet Zoo Deutsche at
saitung here in Berlin and a former
correspondent in several Eastern
European countries including Moscow plus
our very own Roman gunshamenco DW's
Russia analyst joining us from DW's Bon
headquarters
a warm welcome to you all Let's uh start
with this Putin keeps escalating the
referendum's Sham referendums we have to
say nuclear threats annexations and
possibly even sabotage of gas pipeline
even though that's not confirmed so
let's talk about the pipelines for a
moment and I'd like to start with you
Roman uh in which way would Russia
benefit from blowing up these Pipelines
well I guess there are just a few points
how Russia could benefit benefit from it
the most obvious is this sends gas
prices
um Sky High so they are high now
extremely high and they are still
getting even higher and higher so Russia
will profit from that
um I'm not a legal expert but I think
this could
um lower the pressure on Russia to
deliver some gas and to fulfill its
obligations because
um Russia um cannot can say now well we
don't know what happened we were we were
it will take time to investigate we do
not know whether we can point and say
for sure who did it so um when Russia
refused to take German turbines from
Siemens to deliver gas it's one thing
now it's it's a different story
um of course this will put enormous
pressure on the Societies in Western
Europe where people are taking to the
streets to protest against High Energy
prices and last but not least I think
this is also sending a signal to the
West look what we can do we can heat
your infrastructure under the sea and
there are important not just gas or oil
pipelines but also communication lines
between United States North America and
Europe and Russia could could just hint
at that and sell and say look we can do
it Maria do you agree is is a Putin
trying to send a signal to the West here
if it's so this is a very bad signal I
should say because that means that he
definitely believe uh West that
they're really eager to switch to other
sources of energy
and because it's very difficult to
repair it I mean almost impossible to
repair all this stuff and this is
millions billions of Euro
so if he believes that and he decided
physically tear up this connection what
does it mean I mean that means that he
is in his very Final Phase of like of
his being as a president as a leader of
the country running the bridges if you
will absolutely absolutely and this is
very bad news and the the main question
for me now like will he use tactical
nuclear weapon then we come to that in a
moment Daniel first
do you think it is possible or even
likely that Russia is behind these
attacks on the gas pipelines yes I think
it is very likely of course we don't
have any proof no Western Government has
said so far that it was Russia I think
it is likely and the fact that Russia
denies it is no proof at all Russia has
denied many things why why is it likely
I think it helps Russia right now in its
main goal uh to create fear to create
fear and to destabilize the west and to
break the Western Front supporting
Ukraine that's the main goal right now
and it supports this goal so I think yes
it is very likely that Russia did this
so an another move is of course the
referendum uh drive there in Ukraine
Vladimir Putin is pushing ahead with his
plans to Annex large parts of Ukraine
and these so-called referendums in areas
of Ukraine that are controlled by Russia
are just his latest move
[Music]
world to see
polling stations exercising their right
to vote and saying what Putin wants to
hear
this means a lot to us because we are
Russians by nature and now I hope we
will become Russians for real we are
with Russia Russia is with us
anyone who doesn't want or is unable to
visit a polling station will be visited
by an election worker who will go to
their homes to collect their ballots
it's difficult for residents in
russian-controlled territories to avoid
voting
for some ukrainians it became the
perfect time to leave these territories
once and for all
the referendum is a violation of
international law it is illegal
we hear that people in the occupied
areas are forced to vote at gunpoint
Kiev calls Putin's referendum a
propaganda stunt while the West is
citing international law to call it
illegal
how much support does Russia really have
in the occupied territories
and that's a question I'd like to pass
on to Roman In Bonn the referendants
obviously are hashan we have established
that many times but a lot of people in
the dompas are indeed pro-russian if
these referendums were real how much
support could Putin expect
well it is a um very theoretical
question because
um to conduct a democratic referendum
there you first need peace you need a
possibility for all the hundreds of
thousands people who fled the region to
come back uh you need observers of
course uh and you need
um you need Democratic parties things
that we do not have there and and you
know um first of all
um you need no soldiers there are no
guns there can be no fair or Democratic
voting with at gunpoint right but um
back to your question
um I think these are four regions and
the situation is uh different in two of
them so the first the regions Donetsk
and Lawrence which are the factor of
fact factually occupied by Russia since
2014
at least parts of them and uh there we
have people who are living there
um most of them or many of them
um supported Ukraine uh supported the
idea of staying in Ukraine we don't have
a recent data but some data conducted a
few years ago suggested that they didn't
want to join Russia Even after spending
years there but the situation could have
changed in Russia starting this this
open War in February because of the
shelling have a shelling in Russian
propaganda and I do believe that maybe
some some people maybe most of people
who live there in in the region of
Donetsk in the city of Donetsk itself
could support joining Russia but it
doesn't mean that that gives Russia a
right to Annex that territory in the
south of Ukraine in the region of her
son and uh parts of the Parisian region
the city of the bridge itself is still
on the Ukrainian key of control the
situation is very much different and
we've seen protests against is the
Russian occupation there in March and
April
Russia responded to that with heavy
reprise also again the population there
but still I think the general mood is in
the South much more pro-ukrainian than
it is in the East now I'd like to bring
in a viewer comment from one of our
YouTube viewers in in the last show Jeff
Simkins he said stop talking about
settlements this is win or lose and
zelenski also said that annexations
would make peace talks impossible Daniel
does that mean fighting to The Bitter
End uh I'm afraid yes I'm afraid that
the signal uh that uh this actually
sends uh the annexation the annexation
and that's what we have to expect of
those territories is there is no room
for negotiations and that's something
that we have to understand uh
um from a Russian point of view uh this
will be Russian territories from the
point of view of Russian propaganda
that's very important this will be
Russian territory so there's nothing to
talk about and that's what we have to
understand and that's what we have to
understand in the question of support of
Ukraine what are we supporting Ukraine
for we're supporting Ukraine to uh to uh
to enable it uh to regain as much
territory as possible uh Maria you uh
mentioned a minute ago uh the nuclear
threats uh these annexations do you
think uh that Putin will use them
to justify
a nuclear attack I think unfortunately
this is a direct connection
I think referendum needed for declare
this is a new border let's make the
negotiations
and we will stop the war the West
Ukraine and the West they say no What's
Next Step Will the west say no though
when if if Putin steps up to the table
now and says okay we have now annexed
these bits of Ukraine we're happy with
it we stop fighting Will the west how
will the West respond
I think the answer is on Ukrainian side
and they of course will say no they
couldn't say yes after all this and yeah
so what will be the next step I think
there are several scenarios and one
scenario at least it's uh to make this
uh tactical use of nuclear weapon and
then with this poor guys mobilized in
Russia go to this territory where will
be chaos and death and I don't know
desperation and make this Bitter End
I can only say what the chancellor was
said the chancellor said we will not
accept this this is not how it's going
to work that Russia says okay we we uh
occupied the territory we wanted to
occupy and now let's talk and we keep
what we have uh that's not how it's
going at how it's going to work and I I
think it's not how it should work
because what's the message then
whatever territory Russia in the future
will say it will take it can take then
because that's what we're saying and I
don't think that uh Europe can agree to
this and I don't think this American
president will agree to this a future
president might who knows
uh Roman Hebrew Putin will undoubtedly
also conscript man from these annexed
areas to fight against their their own
countrymen in in Ukraine uh do you think
that's realistic that they will actually
fight
well this is already happening and uh
this has been happening for some time
now especially in the regions of Donetsk
and luhansk people have been fighting
there on the side of de facto Russia for
half a year at least and some of them
even in the years before yes they are
fighting the morale is low and we've
seen that the Ukrainian success in the
north of Ukraine in the region of khakif
where in early September the Ukrainian
Army was able to
um liberate large parts of occupied
territories and which was probably one
of the most successful Ukrainian
operations in the start of this war
um the part of the Ukrainian success was
that in those parts there were a lot of
conscripts from donbass so people who
are actually ukrainians and were forced
or some of them maybe wanted to fight
against Ukraine so there was very low
morale there and they just fled so you
mentioned hello morale and that leads us
now nicely to our next little report
Putin has also mobilized 300 000 more
men to fight in Ukraine Russian men that
is but the mobilization has hid a big
obstacle thousands of would-be
conscripts just don't want to die for
Putin's Imperial aspirations and are
fleeing Russia in droves mostly to
neighboring countries
a quick I do and then it's time to say
goodbye
Andre has been drafted and must now go
to war
[Music]
I have mixed feelings but mostly fear of
the unknown
these are the scenes all over Russia
families bidding farewell to men Fathers
and Sons
300 000 reservists have been conscripted
Putin's partial mobilization has begun
but many are not boarding the buses to
the front
instead they are leaving the country as
quickly as possible there are estimates
that more than a quarter of a million
men have already fled within the past
week
we have a choice either we go to the
front or we go to prison
anyone who takes to the streets to
protest the war is also threatened with
imprisonment the police quashed these
demonstrations with brutal violence
in Siberia a reservist shot a draft
Dodger in the head out of pure anger
critically wounding him
murder and death have reached the center
of Russian Society
will Putin have enough soldiers for his
War
yes Maria Willie I mean we just did the
report we heard the number 250 000 that
have uh left what are you hearing
well the yes
yes the numbers is absolutely the same
of the numbers of the troop uh the
border on 24th of February it's just
like symbolic a number it's uh around
200 000 but probably more today and
we'll be more in the next days if they
will not shut the borders because this
is a huge possibility they will do it
today or tomorrow yeah and um
25 million of men in Russia could fight
I mean theoretically so there are many
people left what's the mood then in in
Russia about this mobilization what are
you hearing
ah people are in Terror absolutely
because what's uh it's like 24th of
February again and for many people in
Russia it's the first time because they
denied
the idea that Russia could invade other
countries especially Ukraine which is so
close in many senses to Russia and
yes so now they could not deny it it's
like just
in front of their faces and their
husbands and their sons receiving these
militaries
letters and yeah and this is a huge
theater and people try not to stay at
night at their Flats in here that they
will come for them
I'm talking about those who could not
flee the moments and many of them could
not because people in the poor regions
in foreigners and Siberia like north of
Siberia they just couldn't make it I
mean they couldn't pay for the airline
tickets it costs a lot several days ago
the airline ticket to Yerevan the last
one costs around 2 million Rubles it's
like how many it's 9 000 Euro no that's
cool you can imagine that says something
so people wonderfully probably but they
could not so they will choose between
jail and the war as you've seen yeah you
do and then the uh the view from from
neighboring countries former Soviet
republics what what are you uh what are
you seeing there
well that's interesting because uh um
they of course uh they're of course
worried look at Kazakhstan for example
they're welcome very much they've
welcome they welcome those they welcome
those uh those people Georgia as well
that is not surprising Georgia is in a
position to what is uh what is happening
in Russia yes of course they are they
are a little bit worried that the
balance might not be not be uh too
favorable uh but uh this is one of the
things we see that uh that uh Putin is
losing support even in countries and at
regimes that have been quite supportive
of course for us outside of Russia
it's a little bit ambivalent we have
been looking at the situation where we
were
seeing a society uh enjoying summer
while we had a terrible war in Ukraine
and many people didn't seem to care a
lot now they care
I think from our point of view it's good
if men leave and don't want to fight but
still it's hard to forget that Russian
Society did not really care a lot about
this war before talking about Russian
Society I would like to put that
question to Roman there
as we said earlier this conscription
Drive makes it very palpable for average
Russians all over the country that the
war has arrived in their country will it
change the mood
well it is already changing the mood and
um it's it's an experiment we haven't
seen for decades in Russia since the
Second World War I would say we haven't
seen this in Afghanistan in the 80s or
when Russia was fighting in church now
in the 90s so it is a completely new
dimension for the Russian society and it
takes time for the society to digest
what is really happening and I think it
is a very great danger for Vladimir
Putin but he thinks he can ride this
wave and
um
um I have this idea that maybe he's
actually
um he thinks it is going according to
the plan because remember when he first
spoke When The War Began he said it
would clean the Russian Society so
people who are against these this war or
against me as president they will just
be killed or go away and now we are
seeing a kind of consolidation that he
actually wanted people who don't want to
fight who do not support him are fleeing
the country people who stay who go who
just sitting on that on those buses and
and uh let themselves be driven to the
front line and they'd probably die in
the coming weeks or days or months
um this is what his plan was so um from
that point of view it is going according
to his plan he is consolidating the
society so don't we think that this
will actually increase the protests what
what are you hearing there from from
Russia
probably but it's not question of days
unfortunately and probably
we have this weeks and months to wait
until people will be brave enough to do
it because it was the years and years of
Terror actually it's very difficult to
go to the street knowing for sure that
will take you away they will be you will
be raped I don't know even kills in
police and so it's you have to be a hero
to do this and absolutely desperate hero
how many is such a people in society in
any society so people should be angry so
much that at the same moment the whole
nation will just stand up and go to the
streets if one million people will be on
the streets of Moscow that will be the
end of Putin is there absolutely but it
should be a moment a moment of huge
National anger what I want to say uh and
which I say very
important I think everybody which I
think very important to say that we have
two biggest National shame I mean
Russians uh the first one that's lack of
empathy to ukrainians
and you were talking about society which
lived through next summer but this is
all right this is how things are now we
know how it happens during Second Grade
World War because in some places they
were a huge fight and a lot of places
people just live through the summer but
for Russians it could be so they should
do absolutely opposite things they
should stop tanks I don't know whatever
but they didn't and they didn't even
believe they made them do not believe
that this is true and the Second
National shame is that mothers just send
their children to die to the front I
couldn't I couldn't believe this only in
jakastanin caucus's region uh people are
um
Brave and I've been like
strong enough to to go to the streets
and mothers do not they're just not
afraid of anything because the biggest
scary of a mother that to see her own
child to dying so what else what else
should happen but dagger start is an
interesting point absolutely because
because of course they ask themselves
why should they die for a Russian Empire
and this is going to destabilize the
Russian Empire as we see it today a lot
I think because put into told for years
that the West want to divide us they
want to see the whole Russia they wanted
to separate it by regions we will never
do this but he's doing by his own hands
exactly but you have a video from
yakutia I mean we are like honest West
where a guy said oh I mean I don't have
any against the thought to defend my
country but this is not my War this is
the war between Russia and Ukraine he
said he's from yukuza I said like what
really so fast so this is a huge Menace
for Putin but probably in another way
than just brought us on the streets I
have to interrupt you here we have to
come to our final round of statements
and uh I want to ask a question that you
hinted on you called it a Russian shame
um in the big picture what does this war
No Matter How It Ends mean for Russia's
plays in the world in the future briefly
if you can uh it's a catastrophe it's a
catastrophe because economically it's a
catastrophe it is it is talking about
place in the world even countries like
China are not going to Ally with a
country that I hope uh will be defeated
in a way that we all have to hope that
Russia Russia will at least be defeated
in Ukraine so it's a disaster Roman
what's your view where where does this
war leave Russia in the future
well I think we're witnessing the last
phase of Putin's Rule and Russia as we
knew it under booting for more than 20
years is ending and the new Russia will
be weaker much weaker in the world than
it was before Maria
um
I hope pressure will be a better place
to live after all but when this future
will come you're asking about future but
what distance we're talking about well
the Russia after Putin probably the next
day it will be very bad but how long
will be this next day it's a question
and we know now that many of us
journalists independent journalists from
Russia we couldn't go back in the short
distance future because we will face 15
years in jail and so on but
probably we will couldn't come in five
years as well I don't know I don't know
it's a disaster I agree
thank you very much to my panel here
that was it for today I hope you enjoyed
our discussion and you can join the
conversation if you're watching us on
YouTube we'd love to hear from you put
your thoughts in the comments below
right here and that's it from me I'm
gonna have Alphas in Berlin for me and
the to the point team thanks for
watching
foreign
[Music]
[Music]